hello Pakistan is mourning the death of
at least 93 people killed in a suicide
attack at a mosque in a highly fortified
security compound in Peshawar debris is
being cleared as most parts of the
mosque have collapsed rescue teams have
been retrieving bodies from the rubble
it happened when a suicide bomber blew
himself up during afternoon prayers
Taliban Pakistan denied its involvement
after initially claiming the attack that
targeted police officers let's across
the Kama Haider he's joining us from
Peshawar and Kamal that death toll has
continued to rise
absolutely and as we speak the rescue
and Recovery what is now looking more
like a recovery effort is still still
underway almost
a whole day since that incident happened
and according to the commissioner
confirming that 93 people mostly
policemen have been killed there's been
a ceremonial send-off to those policemen
who lost their lives at the police lines
also funerals taking place across the
province because these policemen came
from several districts so mooning across
the province however we are now also
finding out that there were credible
intelligence reports of an attack that
came out on the 21st of January which
stated that several fighters of the
tarike Taliban Pakistan mostly suicide
bombers were planning a big wave of
attacks across the city of Peshawar and
in the hybrid province that alert was
issued however what you see behind me is
the main entrance to the compound when
you go inside there are four or five
other cordons check posts barricades and
the big question is as to how if despite
the fact that there was a threat alert
how the suicide bomber was able to get
into such a sensitive area get into a
mosque and then detonate this explosive
so definitely complacency a total
failure of the security here in Peshawar
the police of course I will have to
answer for what happened yesterday on
Monday here in the city of peshawa many
are still in critical condition although
those with lighter wounds have been
released from the hospital there is a
fear that the dental could rise even
further and all day long and overnight
we've been seeing that those casualty
figures are mounting so Kamal where do
things stand then right now in the
investigation and what are the next
steps going forward
well in the aftermath of every attack
the details do come out they've been
able to identify the suicide bomber they
also now know that other suicide bomb
bombers are at large waiting for an
opportunity earlier there were reports
that some of them may try to Target the
hospital we have seen that in the past
also where the suicide bombers have
carried out secondary attacks in
hospitals where there is a large
congregation and so the threat alert is
quite high but we don't know what
happens with the investigations on the
ordinary circumstances the head of the
police should have resigned because this
is a total failure but this is also a
government that complains that it had no
money although you will feel you will
find that they are living an opulent
lifestyle roaming around with expensive
SUVs there is no prediction for ordinary
people in this country and although the
elite and the security forces may have
that security and all the perks the poor
people are the most vulnerable these
policemen of course come from poor
families they do not get very large
amounts of salaries and most
investigations in this country are
inconclusive so it'll be important to
see whether they get to the bottom of
this where the heads will roll indeed
although you'll find the politicians
coming to the hospitals for photo
opportunities to try and find out what
happened and the people of course at
large are very angry the social media
posts that you see are blaming the
government for complacency and some
people are even going as far as to say
that the government is now trying to
find an excuse to delay the elections
because this government in this
particular province is an interim
government under the Constitution those
elections should be held within 90 days
so let's see what happens but obviously
people are not happy pay they don't feel
secure and they see this as a not a
failure of the administration thank you
so much Kamal Haider reporting from
Peshawar